so
i know i didn't know if i wanted to
bring this up today but i know i saw
your good friend bob bob saget who we
just had on the show he was sitting
there just passed away what was it two
days ago now
i don't know
the the the thing about that is it's for
i'm i'm at a loss for words um i'm
incredibly shocked um i wrote on
instagram um
i i think i got to tell him i did tell
him we didn't uh bob and i
i consider him a good friend uh i hope
he considered me a friend um i know he
did that's why he showed up whenever i
called him you know we
started out together um over 40 years
ago and not together but that's when we
met you know he's from philadelphia and
he was playing a small club in toronto
and i went to see him and i thought he
was hysterical i never saw somebody that
had that kind of uh you know he just it
seemed like it was improvised you know
he had this flow and he had the guitar
and he was funny and
there was just so much joy in doing
comedy and he was dirty and
naughty and
that's why he was very uh uh
shocking i know people are shocked the
other way when they saw
after full house when they saw his
comedy they were shocked the other way i
was shocked that you know i knew him
from the comedy world that he was the
danny tanner that he was america's dad
that he was america's dad because he did
have this filthy mouth and this filthy
mind but
as i grew to know him
and uh became aware of you know his his
life a little bit he had uh
you know throughout his life he had two
sisters
that passed away
uh
very young
one of a brain aneurysm and one of uh
scleroderma and you know he he was a
such a great um spokesperson for
scleroderma research which he i think
just this year he asked me to do a
little video for i did a little video me
and heidi klum did a little video for
him and whenever i called him i said i'm
just doing a podcast with my daughter
boom he said tell me when i'll show up
um i know that you guys did a bunch of
instagram lives together too we did
instagram live during the pandemic and
even things that weren't broadcast i
would talk to him for hours
about our families he has three kids
also
and he loved his wife kelly and we would
talk about family and we would talk
about you know things that were
important and mental health
and dealing with loss you know i did a
thing for just for laughs with him where
we talked about you know how he coped
with loss and it was always with humor
and dark humor and he could
make you smile at the
at the toughest times and i i just can't
even as i speak here i can't fathom that
he's
that he's not there to call anymore that
he's not there i my heart really goes
out to his his wife and his kids and his
family and you know i hear people and
looking at people
online
you know talking about this this tragedy
but
in being able to process this for a
minute
if there's any positive
i said this to your sister yesterday the
positive is
that you know
as my therapist always says nobody gets
out alive
you know we are all
going to die
and we we just are and
you know a lot of people spend their
entire lives being fearful of how that's
going to happen afraid to suffer
afraid to see more importantly for me as
a family man i don't want to see
family or friends suffer in any way you
know get an illness
he actually
went out in the best way possible
you know i'd really want that for myself
and anybody that i loved he was on the
road he posted you know a few hours
before
his passing about the great audience in
florida he felt like he was 26 again
yeah he said i'm interested in doing the
[ __ ] i'm addicted to the [ __ ] again he's
on the road he's putting together a
special he's loving stand-up um he's
loving his life he's loving his kids
he's texting his kids and then you go to
sleep
and that's it
and what's better than that you know you
say well it's too soon and it's always
too soon
but you know every single day that we're
here you know
you may see an issue with one of your
children which i don't want to see you
know as selfishly as that sounds i'd
like to go first
because i think being the one here it's
all harder for everybody that's left i'd
love to go first and i'd love to not
suffer
so if there's any good that can be said
he went out doing what he loves in a
point in life that he was enjoying and
it doesn't seem like there was any
suffering
it's very apparent that he made a huge
impact on everyone and when you see the
outpouring of how many people and i
don't just mean fans yeah like friends
like everyone he was such a great friend
to so many different people i know you
said that you were so close i know you
guys are really close but to see how
many people have a story but i wasn't
that close i felt really close but it's
amazing how many people felt equally as
close because even if you talk to him
two three times a year he was so present
so there for you so they're wanting to
show up and do
above and beyond whatever your request
was whatever your whatever you needed
however long you wanted to talk it's
always you that would say goodbye before
him he would just give of himself and
you know there are a few people that
i've met i'm in my mid 60s that are good
and nice you know i get to talk to them
a little bit here on the podcast some of
my friends he was one of the true
uh people that we would look up to and
just to have him in your life for as
little and as short as we all have and
we all want longer
is the gift and uh
you know i
i'll say it now and i've said it before
and i got to say it to him
i love you bob
and i always will
you